i mean exxon mobil likes the un paris
agreement all the oil companies support
it they support carbon taxes donald
trump's first pick at secretary of state
was rex tillerson an absolute disaster
one of the first things he did was it
didn't make any sense made no sense he
goes to the arctic and signs on some u.n
clients agreement rex tillerson made no
sense do you know who he is he's big ceo
yeah i mean yeah how do you
that didn't make any sense but he wasn't
even it wasn't like climate skeptics
were oh he's great he was horrible the
exxon mobil
they'll have nothing to do with anyone
they would never give to us because they
don't support our agenda at this point
big corporations support the woke agenda
20 years ago they were all
20 30 years ago the left hated big
corporations now
big corporations quake in the boots of
the left and the progressives and they
love them now so they're not with us
anymore and anyone who claims that oh
these climate denial groups are fossil
fuels explain that example very
important what you just said so
tell tell us why
why would exxon mobil
why would the left or exxon mobil
support the left that doesn't make any
sense because what they're saying the
green new deal
is there's no way in any shape or form
there's a green new deal help an exxon
mobil's business model
well
yes and no the more solar and wind we do
the more backup you need for fossil
fuels and it's who controls it there
were reports years ago of soros you know
groups buying a lot of the old coal
plants that were going out
or buying them and buying fossil fuels
to have them for backups because what's
going to happen here is exxon mobil
has the best lawyers has the best
lobbyists they can control the agenda so
they don't they're not afraid of massive
increases in regulation massive
government control because they
partially control the government it's
hard to tell in today's world whether
government is taking over corporations
or corporations or controlling the
government especially when you're
talking big pharma or you're talking you
know now even big oil or
um
and a whole range of these issues and
then you get into things you know with
the environment social governance the
chinese style credit scores of all these
companies where the boards are
infiltrated just like school boards were
with you know parents found that out
it's the same thing with these corporate
boards so that's one of the pressures
they have they want to look green to the
media and they also know that they can
handle it it crushes the smaller
competition biggest success for american
energy we led the world in co2
reductions because of fracking initially
it was a lot of smaller fracking
operations and recent years there's been
consolidation and taking over what's
happening and it's the same with you
know when a lockdown happens what
happens small mom and pop restaurants
get crushed that's a government designed
you know
planned recession and they they've
called for that to fight climate change
so that's why big corporations support
government intrusion it gets rid of the
small competitors it allows
consolidation causes bankruptcy they can
go in buy up toxic assets why do you
think blackrock loves uh
economic chaos because they can then buy
real estate why does bill gates love
farmers having difficulty bill gates is
now the single largest farm owner in
america so it's a consolidation and all
of these government policies support
that consolidation and the ultimate one
was climate i noticed i'm talking past
tense climate in fact i lead a chapter
in my new book with a quote from richard
lindsen saying it's hard to imagine a
better leverage point for the control of
society than carbon dioxide humans
exhale carbon dioxide it's involved in
everything from plastic to all aspects
of our life to human energy economic
development long life
in human health
but they imagined it and that was a
virus scare and that's what they ended
up doing so that's how that happened but
essentially big business loves uh big
government at this point and that's why
exxon mobil would never support your
average climate skeptic now there might
be some you know
climate skeptics out there who you know
who were lobbyists or something like
that but that's not in my world so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you